[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en
bourgogne et en franche comté pour un
nouveau rendez vous de dimanche en
politique nous sommes au coeur de
l'actualité puisque nous sommes au coeur
du salon de l'agriculture sur ce plateau
de france télévisions
et c'est aux animaux que nous allons
nous intéresser des animaux très présent
dans ce salon vous le voyez avec en même
temps une contestation qui monte autour
des conditions de vie et de mort des
animaux il ya bien sûr la mode du
mouvement vegan les polémiques sur les
oeufs en batterie ou sur les abattoirs
mais au delà au sein même du mouvement
agricole les questions se multiplient
autour de ce rapport aux animaux et les
organisations syndicales se rendent
compte qu'elles ne feront probablement
pas l'économie de ce débat avec nous sur
ce plateau didier ramet bonjour au genre
vous êtes éleveurs et secrétaire de la
chambre d'agriculture de la nièvre
tout à fait emily jane un bonjour
bonjour elle veut aussi membre de la
confédération paysanne et promoteur du
boeuf éthique on va expliquer de quoi il
s'agit jean yves caullet bonjour bonjour
mr d'avalon en bourgogne et ancien
rapporteur de la commission d' enquête
sur les conditions d'abattage c'était
lorsque vous étiez députés tout à fait
et à gadji new bonjour bonjour vous êtes
membre d'une ong ces iwf qui luttent
contre l'élevage industriel alors pour
commencer cette discussion
j'ai envie de vous demander quelle
question faut-il poser est ce que la
question c'est faut-il tuer des animaux
ou est-ce que la question c'est est ce
qu'on traite correctement les animaux
emilie janin
ça dépend de quel type d'élevage en
parle et
je pense qu'il ya quand même beaucoup
d'élevages notamment dans notre région
bourgogne où les éleveurs s'occupe très
bien des animaux où ils sont dans des
modes d'élevage qu'on dit extensif donc
à base d'herbe dans des prairies la
majorité de l'année
voilà vendée on prend en compte leurs
besoins naturels de pâturer de marché
devant les animaux heureux
plus tôt on parlera de la fin quand même
parce qu'on peut être heureux pendant
une partie de sa vie et puis didier
ramet on peut c'est un paradoxe pour le
grand public finalement on peut élever
des animaux les aimer et les tuer alors
ça c'est le mot paradoxe c'est un mot
qu'on a découvert que j'ai découvert il
ya pas très longtemps parce que dans mon
métier dans ma formation dans ma culture
familiale c'est évident qu'on élève les
animaux pour un jour les manger et ça
nous a tout à fait sûr p en tout cas moi
ça m'a surpris que ce débat viennent
comme de quelque chose de surprenant
alors que celles à l'éthique même de
l'éleveur il est le il élève ses animaux
j'élève mes animaux je les ai je les
âges et je les mets en très bonne
condition pour que quand même à la fin
ils zahia l'abattoir et qu'on les mange
ensuite alors on va se poser la question
en revanche de la fin ça fait deux fois
que vous parlez de ça effectivement
les problèmes sont où est ce que les
problèmes sont à gadji new dans les
types d'élevage elle en parlait emilie
janin où est ce que finalement dans tous
les types d'élevage on peut se trouver
sur des situations où le bien-être
animal n'est pas assurée je pense aux
abattoirs je pense aux transports
alors oui la question n'est pas simple
nous assez iwf donc on est une ong
internationale qui a été créé par un
éleveur laitier donc notre
positionnement
ce n'est pas de dire qu'il faut arrêter
l'élevage c'est d'accompagner les
à la fois les consommateurs mais aussi
les acteurs du monde de l'élevage pour
améliorer les pratiques pour qu'il y ait
un meilleur bien-être animal
il ya une question de modèle d'élevage
c'est une réalité il ya des élevages
industriels intensifs et d'autres qui
font les choses de façon beaucoup plus
extensive et puis après il y avait
toujours le problème au niveau des
différents maillons de comment est-ce
qu'on intègre des critères de bien-être
animal important la question se pose au
niveau du transport et elle se pose au
niveau du casque de l'abattage également
jean yves caullet vous avez donc
participer à ce qu'on avait appelé la
commission falorni stella du nom du
député qui s'en occupait ça rejoint ce
que je viens de dire c'est à dire que
dans toutes les filières on peut se
trouver avec des situations difficiles
finalement pour les animaux c'est ça qui
ressortit ou où il ya quand même des
typologies particulière non pas par les
paroles de typologie particulier a
simplement effectivement l'élevage est
un ensemble depuis les conditions
d'élevage de transport d'abattage de
consommation et un grand nombre de
difficultés viennent du fait que les
maillons de la chaîne s'isole les uns
des autres
le consommateur ignore les conditions
d'élevage l'éleveur parfois ne se
préoccupe pas trop des conditions
d'abattage l'abattoir veut pas trop
savoir d'où viennent les animaux et
cette spécialisation crée des situations
où peut s'installer destitué des
conditions qui sont défavorables aux
animaux un transport trop long pas
d'abreuvement à l'arrivée c'est aussi
péjoratif pour l'animal que des
mauvaises conditions d'élevage et c'est
un ensemble mais moi ce que je
souhaitais quand j'étais rapporteur de
ce dossier c'était de dire on veut des
éleveurs et des consommateurs proches
les uns des autres et conscients qu'il
faut partie d'un ensemble et qui sont
responsables ensemble d'une mise en
marché d'un produit qui n'est pas banal
alors vous venez de parler de prononcer
le mot de responsables et je me tourne
vers les éleveurs c'est un terrain
difficile à utiliser mais la mort de vos
animaux
c'est quelque chose qui fait partie de
votre métier d'éleveur vous considérez
aussi que c'est de votre responsabilité
la façon dont ça va se passer pour eux à
la fin alors complètement moi je suis
éleveur ça va être ma tantie 36e année
que je vais commencer dans quelques
semaines donc je pense que j'ai un petit
peu de
d'histoire dans ce domaine là et dans
mes premières années d'activité donc je
suis éleveur à côté de nevers un petit
village qui s'appelle limon suis à 20 km
de nevers et à ce moment là il ya 20 ans
a maintenant un abattoir anneau vert
imaginé mot et est abattu à nevers pour
x raisons l'abattoir à fermer ma
coopérative avec qui je travaille depuis
le début avec un abattoir à
venarey-les-laumes en côte d'or
donc ça m'a changé je me suis dit mais
qu'est ce qui va se passer
donc je me suis intéressé réellement je
suis allé là bas et même là le directeur
d'abattoirs a invité les éleveurs du
département allait voir comment ça se
passait et on a été rassuré la façon
dont la bouvry alors c'est l'endroit où
les animaux arrivent après descendu du
camion où ils peuvent boire un goy rae
se re se remettent un petit banc en
forme et du coup ça me surprend pas et
j'accompagne volontiers la démarche qui
consiste à continuer d'envoyer mes
animaux à venarey-les-laumes par exemple
emilie janin même question oui en plus
vous mettez souvent en scène sur les
réseaux sociaux avec vos animaux mail
leur mort c'est pour vous c'est intégrer
aussi oui ça fait partie du métier
surtout que oui ça fait partie du métier
c'est pas parce que ça fait partie du
métier que c'est simple après voilà mais
ça fait partie du métier mais comme je
dis à certains certains journalistes ou
certains consommateurs que je rencontre
assez souvent sur la ferme puisque
jouant en direct c'est pas tous les
jours sur 365 jours par an on va me tuer
peut-être dix jours par an des animaux
mail et tous les autres et 355 autre
jour on s'occupera de donner la
naissance de s'occuper de les nourrir et
c'est vrai qu'à jean yole e s que ce
moment du transport la mort c'est une
zone grise un petit peu c'est quelque
chose dont on parlait peu jusque là
c'est une zone qui c'est vrai du fait de
la spécialisation est parfois mal connus
mal connue des professionnels de
l'élevage en baisse c'est quoi la
spécialisation ça veut dire que parce
qu'il ya des gens qui élèvent et puis ya
des gens qui s'occupent de tout et
finalement on a coupé un peu ces mondes
là voilà exactement il ya souvent une
spécialisation qui était même au sein
des élevages et ensuite aux différents
maillons et l'abattoir et parfois une
zone moins connus sur lequel l'éleveur a
pas toujours une visibilité et sur
lequel les consommateurs aussi non pas
une visibilité
c'est important pour nous qu'on arrive à
décloisonner et qu'on arrive à faire
comprendre aussi au consommateur que la
viande qu'ils consomment
il faut tenir compte des conditions
d'élevage c'est la durée de vie de
l'animal c'est l'homme le plus longue
période donc c'est important d'y
consacrer aussi le temps important et
puis également le transport et
l'abattage qui ne sont pas à négliger et
qui sont souvent un des problèmes
principaux pour l'abattage c'est souvent
très regroupée donc une des solutions
importante à mettre en place c'est
d'avoir un maillage territorial des
abattoirs il soit suffisant pour que il
est moins de transport pour que l'animal
soit abattu le plus près de son lieu de
naissance
alors ce maillage territorial sa
ressortait du travail de votre de votre
commission
on dit souvent qu'en france par exemple
il ya beaucoup moins d'abattoirs qu'en
allemagne où dans d'autres pays
oui alors effectivement c'est quelque
chose qui est majeur dans l'organisation
de la du maillon final de l'élevage il
ya eu une période de regroupement
considérable des abattoirs moi j'ai même
connu la période où les bouchers pouvait
abattre c'est ce que leurs étals j'en ai
dans ma famille on a regroupé à la fois
pour des raisons économiques et
techniques mais aussi un peu pour
soustraire à la connaissance de la
société cette étape qui était jugé
finalement pas très agréable
la regarder alors effectivement un
maillage plus étroit permet de diminuer
les transports et donc en termes de bien
être animal c'est quelque chose mais
faut pas oublier aussi que pour avoir de
bonnes conditions dans un abattoir il
faut investir des sommes considérables
et que des petits abattoirs qui ne sont
pas bien conçu font plus de tort que des
grands même s'ils sont un peu loin
parfois
et qu'en tout cas la thématique qu'on
avait examiné c'était le rapprocher le
lieu d'abattage avec des systèmes
éventuellement mobile qui pose des tas
de questions aussi hein c'est pas
magique
on va y venir puisque c'est pour ça que
meloni ses patients le transport est là
nous parlons d'animaux qui nous touchent
de très près des bovins des ovins et
porcins mais je peux vous dire que le
transport d'animaux de volaille
ça peut être regarder aussi alors ça
disais quoi le résultat du travail de
votre commission qui a des problèmes
beaucoup de problèmes pas beaucoup de
problèmes c'est quoi quand même mais
voilà il faut quand même qu'on fait
alors un moment donné il y avait si vous
voulez quelques difficultés de non
conformité aux règles qui ont été
rectifiés mais il y avait surtout un
certain nombre de problèmes
1 la transparence la méconnaissance donc
on proposait des commissions de suivi
local comme il y en a pour d'autres
installations classées pour que les élus
les éleveurs les consommateurs puissent
savoir ce qui se passe autour d'en avant
et après l'abattoir il y avait des
difficultés de formation des personnels
et de reconnaissance de leur technicité
faut pas oublier que c'est des gens qui
font ce travail là et que c'est un
travail qui peut s'avérer pénible
et puis il y avait également cette
thématique économique de qui doit
assumer le coût des investissements
nécessaires pour parfaire les systèmes
pour améliorer le maillage est ce que
c'est le prix du produit fini est ce que
c'est le consommateur est ce que c'est
le contribuable
c'était et est-ce qu'il ya des solutions
techniques comme l'abattage plus près
alors on va y venir un mot quand même
magazine you sur le l'industrie et le
côté batterie par exemple pour certains
animaux
de votre point de vue parce que vous
vous lutter contre ça
c'est ce qui génère du mal être animal
alors l'élevage ce que vous dites
l'élevage en batterie sa vie relève ce
que nous on appelle plus là généralement
l'élevage industriel intensif plus
précisément en fait c'est des conditions
d'élevage ou départ
la densité de parler souches
sélectionnées pour une croissance rapide
de par l'utilisation de certains
systèmes comme les cages par exemple on
va limiter et empêcher et de pouvoir les
comportements naturel de l'animal y en a
beaucoup en france il y en a beaucoup en
france 2 ça parce que la voilà on parle
au grand public en france on abat chaque
année plus d'un milliard d'animaux il y
en a à peu près 80 % qui sont dans les
élevages industriels d'accord la majeure
partie de ces animaux dont elle va
industriel ça va être les allées les
élevages de cochons les élevages de
volailles poules pondeuses faut savoir
80 % de la volaille du poulet qu'on
consomme est issu de deux systèmes dits
intensif ça veut dire que toute la
discussion qu'on a là sur la qualité des
animaux de grande qualité qui sont au
salon s'est pas complètement
représentatif aussi toutes les filières
10 dirhams
oui non pas moins la filière volaille je
la connais pas beaucoup j'en ai juste
une anecdote anneaux a donné un niveau
de mon département
en ce moment il ya des indes et des
acteurs de la filière volaille qui
cherche à trouver des éleveurs et on
s'est dit au départ nous à la chambre là
je vais reprendre ma casquette chant oui
effectivement à manier vous pouvez dire
multiplier les types de type d'animaux
de la vente a essayé de lui donner une
piste nouvelle à des élevages qui vient
d'un petit peu en difficulté de
l'économie et on s'est dit ça serait
peut-être bien d'aller vers de la
volaille label rouge nous aurons deux
ors et finalement on nous a rétorqué
mais c'est pas celle là qu'il se vend
alors comment on fait pour ceux qui
choisissent de faire un élevage comme ça
d'aller vers un élevage plutôt mieux
mais qui risque d'avoir des difficultés
économiques ou d'aller vers un élevage
plutôt moins supportable médiatiquement
mais qui est attendu en tant que produit
par le consommateur là ça nous laisse et
on y met on y met la dimension
économique dans ce que vous me direz
c'est un mal être quelque part de notre
part on sait pas comment je juge et un
tuba cakir agir dans ce domaine
un mois et demi déjà là oui ça me fait
réagir je m'interroge toujours quand les
filières cherche de nouveaux producteurs
pourquoi ils ont besoin de changer
vraiment de nouveaux producteurs
qu'est ce qu'ils sont devenus leurs
producteurs
qu'ils ont depuis un certain temps on a
beaucoup qui arrêtent ce système
industriel parce qu'il n'est pas
rémunérateur
parce qu'il est source de de mal être
aussi pour ces éleveurs parce que voir
est élevé dans ces conditions là c'est
pas agréable
voilà il ya aussi ça alors on conduit un
essai dans le domaine bovin justement
dans le domaine bovin on avance dans
notre émission je le disais vous êtes
promoteur du boeuf éthique ml jana oui
ça a été évoqué par jean yves caullet
l'idée qu'on vienne abattre les animaux
dans les fermes
alors on se dit actuellement français
interdits ont fait ça dans les abattoirs
et des normes sanitaires vous avez pas
le droit est ce que vous allez pouvoir
le feu pourquoi vous voulez faire ça
d'abord ah oui d'abord pourquoi et
ensuite est-ce que ça peut se faire si
vous nous direz ce que vous en pensez si
c'est une piste d'amélioration
alors pourquoi on ya pensé moi je suis
engagée depuis très longtemps sur ma
ferme une quinzaine d'années dans la
vente directe et la recherche sont sans
cesse d'améliorer la qualité de la
viande et qu'il est clairement prouvé il
ya eu des recherches au niveau de l'inra
que le stress en vend la mise à mort
entre le transport ou juste avant la
mise à mort influence vraiment beaucoup
la qualité de la viande au départ
d'ailleurs juste à des conséquences ça
peut avoir des conséquences sanitaires
est ce que des animaux qui ont peur
quand il meurt sa dernière mais d'un
point de vue gustatif que la viande
c'est très très important et donc quand
on élève des animaux pendant quatre cinq
six ans voire plus pour faire de la très
très bonne viande et que ça peut être
saccagée entre guillemets en quelques
minutes c'est juste révoltant et c'est
très frustrant quand on fait très bien
son boulot comme moi et donc du coup
abandonné à quelqu'un m'a dit il ya
système d'abattoirs mobile qui existe en
suède
d'accord j'ai été le voir c'est juste
un abattoir mobile aux normes
européennes 84 2004 c'est qui est sur
des petites roulettes et je me suis dit
ça c'est intéressant et ça m'intéresse
et je leur ai dit c'est aussi pourquoi
que les bêtes se rendent pas compte
disons les mots prononçons les mots les
bêtes ne se rendent pas compte qu'elles
vont mourir qu'on va les tuer il ya ça
aussi où c'est pas vraiment qu'elles se
rendent pas compte c'est que quand elles
sont ramassés d'un système classique
souvent elles sont mises dans des
camions elles sont mélangées à d'autres
ce troupeau qu'elles ne connaissent pas
les vaches des animaux qui se repère
beaucoup à leur actif donc juste par
l'odeur de se mélanger avec d'autres
animaux ça les stresse elles peuvent se
battre et c'est et à la longueur du
transport en camion qui peut être
transport qui peut être dommageable ya
l'arrivée sur place dans les abattoirs
tout ça moi je n'avais pas envie d'y bon
alors il ya pas si ça va pas se faire ça
va se faire ça va se faire est ce que ça
vous intéresse alors veille dans la
nièvre vous n'êtes pas loin moi c'est un
dossier que je connais pas beaucoup donc
je prends des risques
moi depuis quelques mois avec que six
autres collègues on s'est lancé dans les
circuits courts et à ce titre pour
essayer de rayonner sur le département
on utilise le l'abattoir de corbigny
donc ce que vous dites je sais pas si
j'irai jusqu'à a utilisé un système
comme le vôtre mais déjà là on est
presque un abattoir de proximité
l'animal pas très tôt le matin par un ou
deux deux c'est mieux parce que comme
vous le dites
ils se connaissent ils se reconnaissent
ils sont moins - ce précédent dans les
nouveaux lieux qu'ils des cours et une
demi heure après et trois quarts d'heure
après y passa à l'abattoir et il n'y a
pas de ce stress que vous décrivez enfin
en tout cas j'ai pas découvert ce stress
jusqu'à maintenant on est dans un
département la nièvre que je connais
bien je connais bien un batteur d'un
kobe vous avez des abattoirs pas trop
trop loin c'est pas le cas de tous les
départements
il ya des départements et vous le savez
à corbeny mais c'est le cas aussi à
venarey-les-laumes c'était de la batteur
qui sont privées qui sont pas
accessibles et qui ne rendent pas
forcément la prestation de services à
d'autres en tout cas corbigny il était
jusqu'il n'ya pas longtemps j'ai réparé
si cabinet seuls les adhérents non non
non ce n'est pas comme ça que tu as far
bernard et les laumes série gars seul
bigard l'utilisent par exemple il attend
à 20 minutes de chez moi moi je peux pas
utiliser pour faire de la prestation de
services donc je vais à autun pour faire
la prestation de services tous ces
problématiques sont compliquées jean
yves caullet l'abattage vous l'aviez
évoqué dans le oui dans la tension
l'abattage halal on a on a grâce à des
gens qui connaissent bien le sujet
évacuer une chose c'est que l'abattage
le plus près du lieu d'élevage c'est pas
non plus quelqu'un qui va se promener
dans le pré que me dit tiens je vais
tuer celle là c'est quelque chose
non mais parce qu'il ya un peu aussi on
dit toutes sortes de vesely c'est pour
ça qu'on vous a réuni aussi pour
l'aborder c'est sûr qu'il s'agit
effectivement un abattoir qui représente
toutes les garanties techniques et
sanitaires qui doit être armé si je puis
dire par des gens en droit français avec
un vétérinaire etc
ça c'est pas un abattage sauvage c'est
simplement que la machine elle est sur
roulettes
alors moi comme la commission d'ailleurs
dont j'étais le rapporteur on était
favorable à l'expérimentation de 7,19 ce
dispositif
ça peut d'ailleurs s'articuler avec des
abattoirs de proximité
parce qu'à un moment donné il faut quand
même stocker les carcasses il faut quand
même passé dans le circuit chambre
froide donc avoir des points wii wheel
abattoir mobile va en quelque sorte se
re remettre en condition de travail
ça me paraît possible en revanche ça
peut déstabiliser des petits abattoirs
de proximité parce que si les éleveurs
sont nombreux à utiliser cela est bien
évidemment ils n'auront plus besoin de
quelques installations fixes de petite
dimension
moi je suis favorable je n'aime pas
qu'on interdise d'expérimenter quelque
chose qui répond aux règles
ce serait le cas il faut le faire
j'espère que ça va se faire on est
d'accord et mini jungles ça ne peut
concerner finalement que du haut de
gamme vous ce que vous faites c'est près
de l'élevage de luxe on va dire de la
vente directe
il ya tout le reste de la filière et que
ça ne concernera pas le reste de la
filière on et il en est bien d'accord
par contre moi au niveau de la
confédération paysanne c'est clair
comporte des propositions très très
forte pour aider à relativiser
et à développer des outils d'apax
d'abattoirs et de découpe de proximité
parce que sans ça ça avait compliqué de
territorialiser notre alimentation de
répondre à des demandes locales
d'approvisionnement de collectivités
locales de restauration vont se
développer qui sont en train de se
développer qui se voit là et qui sont
actés dans la loi suite au ceges cga
agadji new on a parlé de ça l'abattage
mais il ya des nouveautés comme par
exemple aussi le délit de maltraitance
pour les animaux est ce que ça là
maintenant on va aller on essaie de
lister les mesures un peu ce qu'on peut
faire pour que ça aille mieux
est-ce que ça c'est important est ce que
c'est un peu hypocrite parce que des
lits de maltraitance par exemple s'il
n'y a pas de contrôle dans les
transports dans les abattoirs
quelle est votre position à vous là
dessus oui alors justement notre
position c'est que certes c'est une
mesure qui est utile d'arriver à d'avoir
enfin un délit de maltraitance qui
concerne à la fois les transports et
l'abattage on va juste dire pour les
gens qui nous regardent ça n'existait
pas avant pour les animaux d'élevage
voilà ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
cette heure que ça ne consomme pas là en
tout cas le maillon transport et
abattage
c'est une des propositions du projet de
loi ga ainsi que des peines qui sont qui
sont accentuées le problème c'est que
pour pouvoir appliquer cette disposition
encore faut-il qu'il y ait suffisamment
de contrôle et qui est derrière cette
police sanitaire dans les abattoirs ils
portent pas sur la face et c'est un des
problèmes qui étaient ressortis
d'ailleurs de la commission denquête
c'est lequel contrôle en fait
aujourd'hui il ya énormément ya des
contrôles sanitaires qui sont faits mais
les vétérinaires inspecteurs souvent
passent plus de temps sur la partie post
mortem que sur la partie antennes mortem
au moment où l'animal est vivant et pour
nous c'est important d'accentuer cette
se contrôler pour le bien-être pour le
fonds va dire la protection animale en
parlant de bien-être en abattoir et
c'est essentiel d'avoir une inspection
qui soit systématique au poste
d'abattage à défaut et c'est vrai qu'on
voit qu'il ya des difficultés sa demande
sa demande d'augmenter le nombre
d'inspecteurs mais il ya aussi un doit
pas faire ça on va pas faire ça a pris
mais il ya aussi des outils qui se
développent et notamment c'est la
vidéosurveillance ça c'est quelque chose
que nous en tout cas on soutient
une disposition une des propositions du
rapport
développer la vidéosurveillance non pas
comme la panacée si c'est pas le c'est
pas la solution à tout mais c'est un
outil qui va aider au contrôle qui va
permettre de faciliter et de garantir un
meilleur contrôle
ça ne suffit pas ça ne va pas remplacer
des inspecteurs mais ça va être un outil
de plus alors ça va ça va pas justement
est-ce que c'est pas dans la peau
munitions c'est pas bon et on espère que
justement que le travail parlementaire
va permettre de la joute et de
l'introduire dans la dans la proposition
parce qu'il ya une réelle demande rien
et chargé vous regardez jean yves
caullet en disant ça bien sûr pas ce que
c'était c'était dans le travail de la
commission des revenus par le l'ancien
président de la commission olivier
falorni qui l'art proposé à l'assemblée
si j'ai bien compris
oui les cetc si vous voulez c'est une
affaire extrêmement sensible d'abord sur
la première partie nous proposions
effectivement que la l'intensité du
contrôle se répartissent mieux entre la
partie vivante animaux vivants mise à
mort est ensuite suivi c'est vrai que
spontanément et presque j'allais dire
mécaniquement
l'intérêt se porte plus sur l'aspect
sanitaire qui est quand même très très
lourd de conséquences et on avait
proposé qu' un rééquilibrage
j'insiste aussi sur la formation que les
gens qui traitent des animaux vivants en
abattoir est une formation spécifique
que les gens qui sont à la mise à mort
également qu' une polyvalence des postes
pour aussi une meilleure reconnaissance
une moindre fatigue psychologique aussi
des des gens occupant certains postes et
effectivement on avait dit l'outil de la
vidéo peut être un outil un oeil
supplémentaire bien contrôler et là vous
avez mis le feu oui mais parce que ça
n'est pas un journaliste que je vais
dire ça quand on dit un mot c'est ce
qu'il ya derrière le mot que les gens
entendent nous ne voulions pas mettre
sous surveillance permanente les acteurs
de l'abattoir nous voulions simplement
que le contrôleur de l'activité
l'inspecteur vétérinaire même quand il
n'est pas là puissent regarder a
posteriori ce qui s'est passé sur le
poste quand il ya eu un pépin etc
on avait d'ailleurs précisé des
conditions d'accès aux images
extrêmement précise
ce n'était pas pour pas
c'est sur france télévisions
malheureusement malheureusement le débat
un peu polémique la crainte aussi
syndical on nous fait pas confiance on
va nous mettre sous les yeux de
l'opinion et cetera et cetera a fait que
pour l'instant on n'y arrive pas mais
regardez des choses de visu où les
regarder avec une caméra
si on est qualifié pour le faire si la
loi vous donne là la capacité de
contrôler sincèrement il n'y a pas de
difficulté de principe l'idée au delà de
tout ça l'idée d'un label par exemple
garantirait le bien-être animal parce
que pendant sa l'on parle beaucoup de
concurrence en ce moment concurrence
internationale des accords du mercosur
d'arrivée d'animaux d'autres continents
est ce que pour les éleveurs français
justement se serait glissé ce que par
exemple vous à la création paysanne
guise y penser et garantie de bien être
animal ça peut être pour le consommateur
qui aujourd'hui s'y intéresse quelque
chose d'intéressant
oui c'est sûr d'ailleurs ça fait partie
des conclusions qui a eu dans de
nombreux ateliers du deuxième chantier
des états généraux de l'alimentation ou
à toutes ces préoccupations qui sont
portées par la société civile doivent
être entendus à notre sens elles ont pas
été encore prise en compte dans les
nombreux plans de philia qui ont été
proposées par les interprofessions
c'est bien dommage mais pour les
éleveurs ce une façon de se démarquer
positivement c'est à dire que la
majorité des éleveurs peuvent faire du
bon boulot et il faut il faut il faut le
valoriser sa sas a une valeur qui n'est
qui n'est pas valorisé par leurs
rémunérations pour l'instant il faut le
faire c'est votre avis aussi de dire un
mot et de vue là façon dont vous élever
vos animaux dans la nièvre non en côte
d'or alors c'est là que je peine un
petit peu mais retrouver c'est comme moi
en tant qu'éleveur je crains cette mise
en avant des images qui peuvent dériver
à gauche ou à droite jura continuité
anecdotes
moi j'étais prêt qui sont en bord de
route comme bien des éleveurs en france
et un jour j'avais une vache qui avait
un panaris à bénarès une infection
niveau d anglais elle boitait on aurait
pu penser que quelqu'un qu'ils sentent
qu'ils s'en inquiétaient viennent me
voir comment s'assurer que cet animal
boiteux qui est capable
soyez d'une façon d'une eau non la
personne a pris son téléphone a
téléphoné à la direction des services
vétérinaires qu'est venu incognito c'est
moi voir ce qui se passait et après ils
sont dix nous sommes allés voir votre
vache à la panne avait chez lui 0
gelée je dois la rentrée aujourd'hui
c'est ça qui m'inquiète c'est
l'utilisation qui est faite des
informations que quelqu'un récupère sur
la route parce qu on est tout le temps
en exposition et c'est vrai que l
inverse des délits qui sont pas
démontrés il devait devra l'être parce
que ça nuit à notre image aussi et puis
vis-à-vis de l'équipe de d2 ce qui vient
d'ailleurs je voudrais autant qu'on
s'occupe de ce qu'on fait c'est vrai le
démontrer mais qu'on s'occupe aussi s'il
vient d un de la marchandise d'autres
pays
dans ce conte est la préoccupation de
savoir comment ça se produit parce que
moi en tant qu'éleveur j'ai comme
l'impression de faire des efforts et
c'est justement mouriaux c'est là dessus
car la belle pourrait faire une
différence
je sais pas si le label pourra faire une
différence parce qu'on veut nous mettre
et je reviens un malheureusement niveau
paix que si d'autres viennent avec des
prix plus économique etc à qui on
demande pas d effort de traçabilité mon
label risque de entre guillemets d'être
difficile à vendre juste il nous reste
il nous reste une minute démission et
c'est forcément les éleveurs qui vont
nous le dire on vous avez est ce que
vous avez peur aujourd'hui de l'opinion
publique ou est ce que vous pensez
qu'elle est plutôt dans votre camp et
que ben l'important c'est de montrer
aussi que les éleveurs izem d'abord
leurs animaux moi je pense que la peur
ça sert à rien et elle
par nature j'ai bon le on le voit faire
par exemple aux pays bas là où deux
vaches se sont échappés d'un abattoir il
ya eu une vague de compassion dans les
médias énorme mais ça c'est à double
tranchant pour vous éleveurs c'est à
double tranchant
je pense que la perpétuation d'un
portières n'apporte rien de constructif
et mais dans les échanges avec société
civile que je peux avoir avec mes
collègues avec des consommateurs qui
sont venues des clients avec des amis
mes voisins c'est toujours très riche
d'échangés et je pense que la peur se
construit quand il n'y a pas d'échangé
quand les gens ne peuvent pas
communiquer et sa politique
voilà vous entendez la musique la
musique nous dit que c'est la fin de ce
débat qui pourrait continuer longtemps
merci beaucoup à tous les cadres d'avoir
accepté cet échange qui était un peu on
va le dire une gageur à organiser ici au
coeur du salon de l'agriculture où c'est
pas forcément le genre de thème que les
gens aiment abordés merci beaucoup
d'être venu le faire avec nous au revoir
et bon dimanche
[Musique]